Z what is the difference between and
a brother the question what is the
difference between a Nabi and a rasool
Nai
means a person who is a prophet of God
Ando is a prophet of God who has got rad
who has got a message and the right word
is Messenger so Nai is just a prophet of
God who has been sent down to warn them
to guide them but a prophet to whom a
message has been given a has been given
is called AOL he brings aat brings a
message every rasol has to be a na but
every Nabi need not be a rasol that
means to be a rasol you have to be a
prophet of God now all prophets do not
have ai that has been revealed to them
so all those prophets all the Naes to
whom a a message has been revealed to
them for the whole of mankind or to the
community that Prophet that na is called
as AOL so therefore in the Quran when we
Analyze This mentioned in the Quran in
number 33: number
40 that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the father of any of you men
but he's a messenger of God and the Seal
of the prophets that means he is a
messenger of God that means a prophet
with a message as well it says he is the
Seal of the prophets that mean after him
no Prophet will come so the moment it
says no no Prophet will come into
understood nool will also come because
to become a rasol you have to be a Nabi
to become a messenger you have to be a
prophet so this ver says that Prophet
mammad sallallahu Al wasallam is a
messenger of God and is the last prophet
that means he's the last prophet and the
last messenger after that if anyone
claims that he's a prophet of God or a
messenger of God he require a PCH hope
that answer the question